let's start with miners i saw uh that
miners are now starting to put out their
june reports and a couple of miners have
reported that they've sold not just a
little bit of the bitcoin on their
balance sheet but quite a bit explain
what's going on here and why exactly are
they doing this
yeah so for regular listeners of the
show um you know people that have
subscribed to some of my work uh whether
it's on twitter or just um what we cover
bitcoin magazine pro we've talked about
the the cyclicality of the bitcoin
mining uh industry
and these kind of hash price bowl and
bear cycles so you can think of hash
price it's minor revenue divided by hash
rate so when price a good kind of basic
gauge
or or kind of a mental framework to
operate on is when price is increasing
faster than hash rate
miners their valuations their margins
are all increasing
and when hash rate is is increasing
faster than price or if price is just
decreasing and hash rate steady
or hash rate you know the pain trade is
hash rates increasing price is
decreasing these minor margins really
really get squeezed uh and the asic
values and and leads to some of this
kind of force selling we see it every
single cycle and this cycle i think was
even exacerbated by the fact that we
have these new kind of public markets uh
and and the financing around uh around
that so these miners like hud-8 a lot of
these publicly traded firms we have a
graphic up here
this is the the performance of all these
publicly traded miners since the
all-time high of bitcoin and they've all
underperformed bitcoin itself uh and
there's a reason for that post-china
minor ban uh a bunch of hashrate got
wiped out a lot of these companies
scooped up a ton of rigs and they they
did it with financing did it with
leverage so now that the price of
bitcoin has gone down cash rate has has
subsequently recovered meaning that the
difficulty has adjusted upwards for
anyone that's kind of uh not familiar
with the term difficulty
bitcoin mining has this kind of uh it's
like this oscillator and if more and
more people are mining bitcoin more and
more operations are turning on it gets
harder and harder to mine a block a
bitcoin so you know the other way is
that if hash rate's going down
difficulty adjusts downwards to kind of
ease up a little bit and so since you
know all that difficulty has just
continued to ratchet up it's getting
harder and harder to mine bitcoin more
more costly rather
at the same time the price is falling so
you're seeing a lot of these operations
start to puke up and cover their loans
and that's leading to just kind of
cratering valuations and uh you know
equity market performance
so when you see this happening is this
something that we'll understand when
it's over
and like we'll be like okay like that's
probably they've sold everything that
they're going to sell is there like a
percentage of their balance sheet um is
there some way to evaluate it in real
time and the thought process being with
liquidations we know of some because of
on-chain um analytics or or we're able
to understand you know from past maybe
company announcements hey what is the
general price point at which some of
these liquidations will happen and also
what is the size of it now we don't
understand all of them but these are
publicly traded companies and so how do
you evaluate like how much bitcoin is
there available for them to sell uh and
how do you know when they're kind of
done selling or is it just all after the
fact we'll be able to understand that
yeah so there is some some pretty good
data out there about kind of approximate
break-even levels um a lot of these
these these publicly traded miners have
they still have break-even prices below
10 000 um but those numbers actually
ratchet up as hash rate continues to
ratchet up and difficulty continues to
increase um so my kind of base case is
that we see a new all-time low in hash
price right so that that minor revenue
divided by hash rate uh and and
basically the all-time history of the
you know the trend in bitcoin is hash
price is going lower forever essentially
and what you see are during these bull
markets there's these kind of these gold
rush periods where price dramatically
outperforms hash rate and it's just it's
so hard to actually source and um kind
of
engineer these new asic machines and
then get them out and get them plugged
in the infrastructure takes a lot of
time so there is a lag between kind of
that bull market that golden period of
profitability and you know where these
miners really get squeezed but you've
seen it cycle after cycle i think what
you're really you know what to look for
is you can monitor the hash rate you can
monitor the the kind of the moving
averages or the rate of change of that
hash rate when you see a lot of that's
really start to fall off
that basically means that a lot of these
a lot of these miners these operations
are seeing kind of immense pressure but
the beauty of bitcoin is these machines
don't just turn off forever they're sold
they're liquidated the inefficient
miners have to sell their holdings and
what happens someone else with a cheaper
power source cheaper energy and you know
better more well capitalized they scoop
up the miners they plug them in and they
continue to hash and and they also get
the the benefit of difficulty ratcheting
down
right so uh i think there is still uh
you know a period ahead of us where
these miners are really gonna get
squeezed they're gonna have to be
selling a majority of their stack
there's no longer a period where minor
margins uh you know the profit margins
were 80 90 in the bull market uh and
because of that they had just absolutely
tremendously outrageous valuations uh
that period is over uh and it's kind of
really just every man for themselves at
this point um some publicly traded
miners i believe probably won't make it
to the other side or they'll be acquired
and some will continue to thrive they'll
continue to build and they'll you know
they'll be tremendous performers uh
during the next bull cycle but i think
you know that takes time
when you take a look at something like
hash price explain what hash price is to
everyone and then we can pull up this
hash price percent from cycle low and
you can explain what this is showing us
yeah so hash price it's minor revenue
daily minor revenue so we can see you
know around approximately 900 bitcoin
per day uh our mind um and then we can
just multiply that out by the current
price and then divided by uh just uh
average hash rate so uh using a daily
hash rate isn't really useful because
it's there's so much variance but just
say you know take a seven day moving
average of hash rate uh it's it's a
pretty it's a pretty reliable indicator
of where the you know what that rate is
and because of that we can come up with
this hash price uh this this kind of
calculation and it's a rough estimate
and obviously every minor is different
but this is basically kind of showing
you uh minor profitability and this is
in logarithmic scale so if you want to
zoom in on that chart a little bit uh
hash prices is basically going down for
forever in a tremendous fashion it's
almost like the opposite or inverse of a
bitcoin chart as hash breaks contin as
hash rate continues to just increase and
that block subsidy continues to get cut
right first there was 50 bitcoin mined
every block then 25 then 12 and a half
in may of 2020 that went to 6.25
somewhere in 2024 that'll go to 3.125
um and obviously there's you know
variable amount of fees that are being
paid
to compensate miners as well but we can
see here that these bull markets right
if we look at the hash price uh kind of
uh increase from its all-time low during
bull markets this is kind of that gold
rush visualized right so any miners any
capitalized miners that make it through
the bear they rough it out they're
barely profitable they squeak by but
they're still they're still hashing
during that next bull cycle that's where
they kind of you know that's where you
reap the rewards and so now we're we're
kind of in one of those periods where
hash price is is just flirting with an
all-time low it's all-time lows around
seven cents per terahash right now it's
about uh eight point uh six cents per
per tara hash so we're going to see
another low uh it's going to get even
kind of squeezier for these miners and
their margins uh and and the strong will
survive but the weak you know probably
get wiped